+ 2,3% c'est l'augmentation du nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi dans les Yvelines en
un mois un chiffre en plus forte
croissance qu'au niveau national ou le
taux de chômage a progressé de
1,4%. les Yvelines restent toutefois un
département encore épargnés avec un taux
global de chômage qui s'élève à 7 % à
comparer au 10,5% de la France le
département dans sa partie nord en
vallée de scène souffre notamment de
baisse d'emploi dans l'industrie
automobile à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
certaines communes sont préservées comme
Guyancourt ici dans cette agence 6000
offres d'emploi sont proposées par an et
le taux de chômage est similaire à
l'Allemagne 5,5% pour le directeur de
Pôle Emploi Yvelines à la situation dans
le département commence à se tendre on
est sur une situation où on a plutôt une
baisse des sorties de la demande
d'emploi on n'a pas eu de croissance
significative des inscriptions sur le
mois de janvier par contre il est
compliqué aujourd'hui plus compliqué de
retrouver un emploi
sur les 12 premiers mois de l'année le
taux de chômage a progressé de 11% dans
le département les Yvelines comptent
environ 50 000 demandeurs d'emploi